[Music]  I know she will bring to the demands of  her new role the steadfast Devotion to  duty on which I have come to rely so  much  for the king she's a balancing act what  that means is she's got a real sense of  what normality is and and how to  translate that and bring that into this  quite rarified atmosphere  [Music]  foreign  number one here incredibly unpopular  media coverage she had here  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  people have started to see the person  behind the headlines she was firmly of  the view that you should meet me and you  should judge me on how you find me and  on the work that I do  [Music]  [Music]  it was unbelievably brilliant moved by  the queen to do that just tidying up all  the Loose Ends before she went  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  she will be his Rock like Prince Philip  was the Queen's Rock